Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's again with module three of your stop fighting cancer course.
This is on fighting the cause, dealing with the cause, why we should deal with the cause, why we
should address the cause, and trying to figure out why the medical profession doesn't even talk about
this. I still don't know. I don't have the answer with that, but we'll talk about it a little bit.
So fighting the cause is an important thing. It always has been an important thing to me when we
started seeing cancer patients back in the 90s. It's always been important to me as a functional
doctor because it just makes sense to me. It's just part of my philosophy. It's like if we don't
deal with the cause, then, you know, how are we actually going to deal with the problem? We talked
about that a little bit in the band-aid approach. It's just part of who I am with as my core.
We got to deal with causes. I know that we should use that word in the plural because there's always
multiple causes. Ultimately, there is one thing that ends up getting inside of the cell. We need to
deal with that if we can. So in order to understand that, I think we have to be on the same footing
in understanding what cancer is. So cancer is one thing that gets inside of a cell. Could be an
oxidative product like some sort of oxidizing agent like a poison, like a pesticide or a chemical
herbicide. It could be a bacteria or a virus or a fungus or a mold or something like that that
gets inside of a cell and affects the nucleus. So normally, your cells divide. Most of your cells. Your
neurons don't and most of your cardio cells don't readily go through this process. That's why
cancer in the neurons themselves is rare and the heart is rare. But the glial cells in the brain
is different. So long story short, simplify the physiology here. Normally, your cells will undergo
reproductive cycle. So your skin cells about every six to 12 weeks will reproduce another cell
and then another six to 12 weeks that cell reproduces another cell and eventually the mother cells.
You could say die off through a process of normal, natural program cell death that is called apoptosis.
That's a healthy cell death. So there's different ways that cells die. Cell death through pathology
would be lysis. So if you were poisoned, you die quickly with a poison because you have massive cell
death. Massive cell lysis. So lysis of a cell is basically an exploding of a cell. All the cell
parts, all the different organelles and cytoplasm inside that cell are spewed out over into your body.
You have all this waste production and through this cell death, you die. So if it has to be if it's
death of your arterial cells, your endothelial cells, you could have massive explosion and blood loss
and you instantly die. Depends on where that poison is acting on what cell line that's acting on, etc.
Cell lysis actually takes place when a person goes through chemotherapy.
So any pathological death of a cell is called cell lysis. Normal program cell death that takes place
through normal cell division and then the mother cell died off is a different type of cell death
called apoptosis. Totally different process. The cell goes through these what are called blemines
which is actually these in pocketing of the cells and then walling off and piecing apart
literally through the use of different organelles, one of them lysosomes inside the cell. You end up
reutilizing a lot of the cell components. So it isn't an exploding of the cell and it all break
it up and you have to deal with with waste products from that cell death. It's basically a recycling
of the cell material and reusing of the cell material of the body. It's a very efficient process,
this apoptotic process and there's different things that stimulate apoptosis and there's things
that can hinder apoptosis. So there's actually a couple parts to a cell line going into a cancerous
production. Something gets inside the cell affects the nucleus and instead of that cell let's use
your skin cells again. Instead of that cell line reproducing every six to 12 weeks now it's reproducing
every six to 12 days or worse. So if it's reproducing every six to 12 hours, well that would be at a very
aggressive cancer. So the aggressiveness of the cancer is how fast is it reproducing? So the aggressiveness
of the cancer is how fast is that rate of replication. And then what also happens in a cancer cell
mass is that the mother cells are not going through apoptosis. So they are slightly deformed. They
look different on a slide. They're not healthy normal cells. They're rapidly reproducing and they're
not dying. So they're not going through lysis. They're not going through apoptosis. So the purpose of
chemotherapy, chemotherapy is a poison, an oxidized agent that hopefully because this rapidly growing
cell mass is more metabolically active, it's you could say hungrier. Now this hungrier cell mass
will uptake the poison faster than a healthy cell which isn't quite as hungry because it's not
as metabolically active. So the idea of chemotherapy is that since the cancer is hungrier,
it's going to take up the poison more readily and the poison will kill the cells. Well of course some
of the healthy cells are going to take up the poison too and they could die as well. Of course they're
healthier so the chance of them dying is a little bit less. That's the idea of chemotherapy and in
general it can work but a person can have ill effects of it because you have death of healthy cells
and etc. There's other things so let's talk isn't the one chemotherapy but that's the idea
if we understand what cancer is we can understand why it can be important to address the cause
and I've said in other videos that wow they do all this research on what causes cancer you know
charcoal foods to newspaper ink to pesticides and herbicides and everything but then once a
person is diagnosed with cancer and if they're astute enough to go well Mr. on doctor oncologist
what's the cause of my cancer usually they get a blank stare or we just don't know or use head
bad luck or you have bad genes or whatever it is you know it's very rare that we ever hear anybody
was told that they have a certain cause for their cancer unless they have a broccogene defect
and then it's blamed on genetics or they have positive HPV or something with the uterine or
or some sort of vaginal cancer it is blamed on that but typically cause is never investigated
and partly because they don't really have a treatment that's not really part of the protocol
understand practice of medicine good and bad is that really the protocols in the practice of
medicine called the standards of care really written by the pharmaceutical industry because they
have a quote unquote treatment for it so when there's no treatment for pesticide exposure
causing the cancer well we don't deal with that so that just doesn't exist in their mind
and that's unfortunate so understand what you talk about cause you really have to understand
what cancer is something got inside that cell affected the nucleus and it could be a plethora
of different things got inside the cell affected the nucleus now that cell line is going through rapid
replication and it's not going through apoptosis now here's a little side note when women especially
with cancers that are ER positive PR positive or HER2 positive what does that actually mean does
that mean estrogens are the cause of the cancer therefore dropping estrogen down to nothing with
the rheumatase inhibitor type drugs is going to cure the cancer well no estrogen is not the cause
of the cancer estrogen didn't get inside the cell and cause the cell to go through rapid replication
so what we're thinking about cause we're talking about what affected the nucleus to go into rapid
replication what we're talking about hormone positive cancers that is talking about what's
hindering apoptosis so you have different so a cell goes through normal program cell death apoptosis
because of an internal factor internal to the cell and an external factor external to the cell
the external factor has to do with the cell membrane so your cell membranes have thousands of
different receptors on those membranes that do different things on the cell membranes you have what
are called apoptotic receptors one of the types of apoptotic receptors is called an adol receptor
that bad estrogens quote unquote bad end estrogens can attach to that receptor and block apoptosis
so when a person is ER positive or HER2 positive or PR positive it's shown via investigation and
testing in a laboratory that that person's cells cancer cells have those bad estrogens attached to
those receptors block eat apoptosis it's not the cause of the cancer but it is causing a decrease
in apoptotic function so the cell isn't going through normal program cell death so decreasing
bad estrogens would be extremely helpful in overcoming cancer with these people now do you need to go
on a medical drug apoptotic hormone blocker well that's questionable there are some natural
hormone blockers out there I list them in my book in detail that you can look at and investigate
and start utilizing those you could even use those if you are going to go on an enrolmentase inhibitor
medical drug now a lot of women don't like those drugs a lot of men with prostate cancer don't like
energy deprivation therapy you can reduce these bad hormones quote unquote the ones that attach to
those receptors through natural needs never going to be as good quote unquote as if you took the
drug and completely wiped out all your hormones but there's a lot of side effects of that and negative
is of that too that a lot of men and women don't like so look at that investigate that but that's not
fixing the cause it's fixing part of the cause you could say it's affecting you know the hindrance
of apoptosis but it's not blocking the replication piece hopefully there wasn't too much information
but so understanding cancer helps us understand why we want to look at cause so why does cancer
continue to grow I thought my immune system was supposed to knock down this cancer and destroy it
is it because I have an unhealthy immune system is that why it's continuing to grow well we talked
about one possible reason why it's continuing to grow in that apoptosis is not taking place because
of possible hormone interaction but let's say I have a cancer that isn't hormone related so that's not
the reason well remember cancer is your own cells so it is self tissue now normally in self tissue your
immune system doesn't attack self tissue otherwise we'd all be dead so self tissue is blocked
is your immune system is blocked from attacking self tissue because your T cells what are your
natural killer cells your immune cells have this little receptor on it that your self tissue cells
attached to that receptor and turn off T cell attack to self tissue that's how self tissue is preserved
or protected from your own immune system and the immune system then that's the smart pack of the
immune system so the immune system will then just attack on things that are not self tissue your
immune system is not supposed to get rid of pesticides and herbicides and chemicals and heavy metals your
immune system gets rid of bacteria and viruses and mold and fungus and biotoxins so your immune system
kills biotoxins and then your detoxification process gets rid of heavy metals and poisons and pesticides
and such and that's part of the problem with cancer is that is that we are exposed to way more poisons
and toxins and chemicals than our ancestors were ever exposed to and it can overwhelm our liver
and by overwhelming our liver then these things get shunted to the cells and to the tissues and get
basically stored inside the cells and that is a major cause of cancer is all these poisons that
were exposed to that are stored in the cell could have been something you're supposed to at six
years old and has been stored in the cell for 50 years now and now just happens to affect the
nucleus it is causing this rapid replication so get it wide as cancer keep growing well part of the
reason is that cancer is your own cells so because it's your own cells your immune system isn't
attacking it secondly cancer keeps growing because of possible hormone involvement blockade apoptosis
thirdly has to do with your immune response so lots of things that decrease my immune response
will cause the cancer to uptick we're seeing in the last few years with this advent of this
quote-a-quote virus which is odd because most viral exposures actually cause an immune response to
uptick so when you have a bacterial infection or you have a viral infection you'll end up with an
increased white blood cell count that's kind of how you know you have a bacterial infection or some
sort of biotoxin because you have it acutely spiked white blood cell count but this
quote-a-quote virus that is in the society at the present time is causing a down tick of the
immune response which is quite odd it makes you question whether there's some man-made interference
of this thing and that down tick is causing a huge spike in cancers so how is it causing a huge spike
in cancers well at least one thing at least one piece of the cause is it's causing a down tick
of the immune response so the truth is is that all of us have some cancer cells growing in us and what's
keeping the bed bay is when they get to a certain size our immune system even though they tend to turn
off against self-tissue when it gets to a certain size your immune system should attack it and kill it
if my immune system is suppressed for 80 reason going through a horrible financial time and going
through a very difficult time with my children or my spouse or my work environment my stress is
there so stress increased sympathetic response decreases my immune system response and down my immune
system is down ticked if I have exposure to this weird type of virus that's causing a decrease in
my immune response or if I have a chronic infection or chronic inflammatory response or maybe I'm
exposed to a lot of poisons in my workspace so I have a decrease in immune response because my
body's dealing with just an overwhelm of whatever's going on there are hundreds of different reasons why
but if my immune system is suppressed in any way I'm going to give an advantage to cancer growing
and that is a problem so why does it metastasize so cancer as it gets larger and larger and larger
is giving off what are called circulating tumor cells they're also called cancer stem cells
so that cancer circulating tumor cell breaks off it is going to go into the bloodstream circulate
through the bloodstream get across the epithelial lining of the bloodstream get into another tissue
somewhere else and look for a place to set up home and raise a family and once it starts replicating
there now we have metastasis so while that single cell that single circulating tumor cell is going
through the bloodstream it's not yet rapidly replicating and this is a problem when you're doing
chemotherapy remember I said chemotherapy is going to be more attracted to highly metabolic
tissue so when the cancer is growing and replicating and getting larger it's very hungry so it's
going to gobble up more of the chemotherapy than healthy cells but the catch 22 is everybody has
circulating tumor cells so personally do not put your faith in a circulating tumor cell lab
because that will only pick up circulated tumor cells in that little blood sample that you collected
but your circulated tumor cells are in the blood and in the tissue you could never find out how many
circulated tumor cells you have in the tissue so circulated tumor cells are not yet rapidly
replicating so they're not yet highly metabolic so they haven't started the replication phase
and which is setting up home and raising a family in another tissue so they're not going to be
so affected by the chemotherapy so chemotherapy might effectively reduce the size of a primary tumor
but they really do nothing to kill circulated tumor cells and the other negative chemotherapy
not to knock on that because it could be very beneficial for a lot of people but it decreases your
immune response because chemotherapy is going to be attracted to rapidly replicating or highly
metabolic activity and different cell lines are more highly metabolic your sear here follicles are
more highly metabolic cell line that's why people lose their hair when they do chemotherapy because
chemotherapy is attracted to more highly metabolic cell lines well so as your immune system your immune
system is more highly metabolic, so chemotherapy is going to be attracted to that, and that's
what knocks down your immune response, and it's like, oh, damn it, I thought I needed
a immune response in order to kill my cancer.
Well, you do.
Well, that's the catch story to have chemotherapy, so you better be doing a lot of other immune
stimulation.
So that's where, if you're going to do status of care, you better be doing a lot of alternative
things, too, to help build up your body.
So not against doing chemotherapy, if that's the direction that God is leading you, but
you better be doing some other things as well.
So cancer metastasizes by getting, giving off, circulating to ourselves that is just looking
for another place to grow, and different cancers tend to metastasize to different areas, partly
because of location, breast cancer tends to metastasize to the lung, to the brain, to the liver,
whereas prostate cancer tends to metastasize to the bones and the pelvis and the lumbar spine,
the abdominal cavity.
Well, that makes sense, because that's kind of the location of where it's at.
So we need to look for that as well, and treat that, and that's why make sure you're stimulating
your immune response with whatever approach you're taking.
So this is where why fighting the cause helps, because if you're cleaning up the environment,
if you're trying to deal with the pesticides, the toxins, the heavy metal poisoning that
you may have been exposed to for the last 30 years, or bio toxins that you've been exposed
to, you're going to help prevent that metastasis to occur.
So we can't stop the reason why the cancer's there in the first place by magically waving
the wand over, fixing the cause, but you can help reduce metastasis.
And that's really the goal.
It's 90-some percent of the people who pass away from cancer is because of the metastasis,
not the primary tumor.
So we want to do everything we can to help block that.
There's other things that we can do to help keylate and grab onto, circulated to ourselves,
and I write a lot about that in my book as well.
You want to be active with that as well.
So how do we address the cause?
Well, how you can address the cause, if you're not a patient of ours, is to read my book,
look at my detoxification piece, very important, and start dealing with possible causes that
you were exposed to in your life.
And that's the way to do it.
You have to look at it holistically as much as possible.
We do a cheek swab, and we do some specific testing, but I know this whole series is addressed
to people who can't do that and come to us and have that procedure done.
So for what you need to do, is you need to be lucky at my seven phases of detoxification
book.
I give a ton of information, three that you can download and look at and utilize different
things to help your body getting rid of poisons and toxins and biotoxins in your body and stay
as clean as possible, because that's really the key.
You're never going to be able to not have any toxins in your body.
Detoxification is a lifelong process.
I talk to people every day that go, well, am I going to do a detox?
I don't even like using those words, because you're not going to do a detox.
If you're not detoxing, you're going to die.
So you are detoxing.
So you're still alive talking to me.
You are detoxing.
We just need to help the process.
We need to accelerate the process, heal the process.
That's what the next module we're going to talk about is the art of detoxification and understanding
those phases, because that is so, so key.
So you don't do a box detox that you're going to do for two weeks and now you're healthy
and clean.
That's absolutely ridiculous.
You're going to, you're going to promote that process on a daily basis, because you're being
poisoned constantly, even if you're eating organic and doing everything possible, right?
You're still being exposed to poisons and you're still being toxified.
So we want to constantly be supporting your organs of detoxification so you can help clean
that out constantly.
So we'll go into depth of that, so don't worry.
All right, so I hope I didn't talk too fast.
Maybe I have to listen to this again.
I tend to ramble.
I apologize.
Hopefully this is a blessing to you.
I really wanted to be.
So all right, we'll get into module 4, or just a second, stick with us and walk you through
this process.
Thanks so much.